what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
all right so truth to tell infinity is
turning out to be a lot more popular
than I thought it would be man I didn't
realize you guys would be that excited
about it I didn't really plan on doing
any of the science I just plan on doing
like the main events and it like the
main story itself and it's kind of
talking about the times as we go through
it but like I'm looking at the comments
and and looking at how many of you guys
are watching it I'm just like okay so I
guess we will cover the tie-in with a
black order like crushes the earth
superheroes now this is this is cool
like it's it's one of the coolest things
ever like I do I love the call obsidian
like it's it's one of the coolest ideas
like having Thanos his own order now one
thing I want you guys to bear in mind
this this are the next video that comes
out we actually won't reference this
because I'm recording this after I
recorded that one but we'll make sure
this fits in terms of like the video
playlist and you know being in
chronological order all that kind of
good stuff but initially this picks up
with what the Cole obsidian has learned
that the Infinity stones are basically
gone now remember this comes from the
outrider this comes from a doubt writer
that showed up on earth and it was
looking for the infinity infinity stones
so the Infinity Gauntlet could be
reformed and of course once it reported
back its mind was read and we end up
learning what it is that's going on and
it's kind of interesting because the
Cole obsidian doesn't necessarily agree
with Thanos in Thanos his mind he is
looking to regain absolute power and
even like like supergiant is just kind
of like okay but there's only one stone
left there's only the time stone
remember we covered that in Hickman's
Avengers the New Avengers when the
incursions were happening Captain
America got the Infinity Gauntlet he
tried to push one of the other universes
away and it destroyed the Infinity
stones everything except for the time
stone was shattered and the time stone
disappeared but because of the fact that
it's still there Thanos his response is
you only ever really need one stone and
that makes you God not only that like
what this would do if they don't Scott
the time stone he could just jump back
into the past to the point when the
Illuminati presumably had the infinity
gems he could just kill them all
take the infinity gems jump back to the
modern day have a fully fleshed out
Infinity Gauntlet and retain godhood but
remember it's kind of cool because for
Thanos being God is like it's like a
drug because over the course of its
publication history he's been God a
multitude of times the first time it was
the Cosmic Cube the second time it was
the Infinity Gauntlet you know we saw a
handful of things going on if you read a
Marvel the end he's had like the heart
of the universe the power of the one
above all
and he destroyed the entire multiverse
with that without that kind of power
Thanos has attained godhood in a
multitude of ways and even in his base
form without the Infinity stones
he's crazy powerful I mean he went
toe-to-toe against Galactus albeit
Galactus was in a relatively weakened
state but he managed to like hold his
own against Galactus a cosmic entity so
I mean there's a lot of power to be had
here and it's kind of interesting
because like like the ebony maw kind of
speaks up and is like look I mean sure
we could go for this but like there's
other things that we could focus our
efforts on but again this is an invasion
fleet attack the earth capture these you
know captured the Infinity stones those
are Thanos his direct orders and so what
happens is this conflict takes place in
a variety of different different areas
initially the the opening skirmish
really takes place in New York so you
have like Reed Richards you have our man
Tony Stark and they're using whatever
technology they have at their disposal
but you're talking about super advanced
technology the other part really comes
with like what conduct and this is cool
because black dwarf shows up on the
doorstep of black panther now let me
tell you something man what Conda is
we're villains go to die only a fool
goes to Wakanda starting problems right
everyone loses like no one wins the only
person who really successfully won was
like Doctor Doom and like he started an
insurrection and that's one of the
things I want you guys to be aware of we
already covered the story from Hickman's
Fantastic Four where black panthers stop
being the quote-unquote king of Wakanda
and became the king of the Dead now a
little bit of a refresh here for those
of you guys who didn't see that Black
Panther was king of Wakanda for years
and years and years and years at least
T'Challa was but there came a point when
Black Panther was injured and then like
aqueous are really kind of seated the
throne to his sister Shuri
who took over the role of black panther
the issue with this is that were jacala
would have gone back to that role dr.
doom actually instigated an insurrection
inside of Wakanda allowing a handful of
of really these insurgents to take over
and basically ask everyone including
Sheree and T'Challa himself now this
whole scheme by dr. doom was for the
purpose of acquiring all the vibranium
stores of Wakanda which he did and the
result was that an order for Doctor Doom
to be defeated because vibranium
amplifies magical energy black panther
had to render all vibranium across the
world completely inert but because of
the fact that it was believed that he
had totally shattered the economic
standing of Wakanda basically
obliterated any and all financial
resources that they had ultimately sure
he maintained the role of black
anther empty Tama became king of the
dead but like supergiant shows up on the
doorstep a black panther and unbeknownst
to him gets absolutely wrecked because
why Panther is a beast that's why I do I
love the way Hickman writes Black
Panther because he's like hey man you
know look you can come here and you can
pick a fight just just be aware many
have tried and many have failed but from
here we switch over to Atlantis this is
another thing that I want to I want to
kind of focus on here I want to talk
about for a second the the animosity
between name with a submariner and Black
Panther is only ever has only ever
really been a recent thing I mean for
the most part they were kind of
teammates and I mean they worked
together from Tom at Han but the reason
why there was so much animosity at the
time this story was being written was
because of a story called Avengers vs.
x-men which we've covered and Avengers
vs. x-men saw a man with a Submariner
basically getting one part of the
Phoenix force which was also split among
Emma Frost of the x-men Cyclops of the
x-men a colossus and and his sister
magic the result is that name of the
Submariner launched an attack against
Wakanda and destroy the entirety of the
Necropolis in the whole nine yards so
what cond is still in a rebuilding phase
but in response to this black panther
destroy the entirety of atlantis like
he's sent his soldiers sent his forces
to atlantis invaded it and just raised
it to the ground and so at this point
atlantis is on the verge of complete and
total destruction
so when Proxima midnight shows up on the
doorstep of Maine with a Submariner and
says we're looking for the Infinity
stones tell me where they are or I'll
destroy what culture II Little Kingdom
you have left and so for name of the
Submariner to be told and lantus will be
destroyed whatever little soldiers you
have left they'll be totally annihilated
I'll destroy you and everything that you
know and love and it's like okay I'll do
whatever I have to do in order to make
sure it Landis is safe but vengeance is
on his mind and so when the question is
asked by Proxima midnight where is the
Infinity stones where should I send all
these forces of Thanos
the responsive name of the Submariner is
it somewhere conduct because that way
it'll see just the total destruction of
black panther and everything in Wakanda
itself but from here we move towards
probably one of the best parts of
infinity we moved to the ebony maw now I
love the ebony more oh my god I love
anymore he is such a great character the
whole idea is that he uses words to
basically dupe people into doing things
but he's basically ensnared dr. strange
and that's what's so cool about this is
because you're talking about like the
master of the mystic arts right like dr.
strange has for the most part over the
course of his life seen and done it all
I mean you have all
of characters out there that dr. strange
has has had to contend against that are
insanely powerful then you have someone
like the ebony ma and he just shows up
and just whispers things into the ear of
dr. strange and then suddenly he's
ensnared and so it's interesting and
it's wild because at this moment right
now he's basically just a pawn but at
this point we switch over to the Jean
Grey school now somebody else said I
want you guys to also be aware of the
Jean Grey school and really the x-men at
the time this story is written there
basically in shambles right like this
comes out of schism and we cover the
Schism story that was basically a story
where Wolverine and Cyclops had two
distinctly different views on what
direction the you know Xavier school for
gifted youngsters should go in and
because they had basically
irreconcilable differences they
basically had their own little mini
Civil War and you had Wolverine who
broke off and formed the Jean Jean Grey
school of higher learning and then you
had Cyclops who stayed at the Xavier
school and they just ran two different
institutions but that's why you don't
see like the full brunt of the x-men
here it's basically just Wolverines
x-men team and cyclopses team isn't here
but showing up alongside supergiant and
Corvus glaive this is cool because
Corvus glaive is like the first of the
five right like he's like the first of
the of the cull obsidian but like
supergiant is nothing to scoff at and in
fact supergiant actually goes through
analyzes all the powers of the mutants
who were here and says okay so you have
two types you have alpha mutants and you
have omega-level mutant the alpha demons
don't worry about them the Omega level
ones are the ones we have to worry about
and that's true like we know that from
covering like the omega-level mutant
series you're talking about mutants that
have no definitive end to the power they
possess
it's basically infinite and the first
person she seizes control of is Iceman
because Iceman is probably the character
who's easiest to use to basically freeze
everybody up to completely and totally
take them over but then suddenly you
have Wolverine who jumps in but the
issue with this is that as soon as he
jumps into the fray he's immediately
impaled by Corvus glaive and he's like
done like you're you're done you're
finished man but I don't want to tell
you man but like you're done there's
there's nothing else with you besides
this whole thing like like that's it and
so the result is that switching back
over to Wakanda what we end up finding
out is like super Joe I'm sorry not
supergiant a black dwarf just got rekt
like he was just he was absolutely
decimated but it's kind of funny because
we're Sheree and the other members of
Wakanda would relish in this and
celebrate Black Panther like T'Challa
he's hardened but he's been down this
road a multitude of times especially
when it came to like Ulysses Klaw and so
the idea in his mind is they were
I mean sure they weren't really looking
for this kind of resistance they weren't
really expecting to show up here and get
absolutely select like steamrolled by
Wakanda but once they're here they're
looking for a thing in particular and so
they will come back with a much larger
force and that's what he's concerned
about and so what ends up happening is
that we pick up in the aftermath of this
right like we pick up with thanasis ship
sitting over at Ilyn but it's kind of
cool because you have like the black
dwarf you've got Corvus glaive you got
Proxima midnight you know you have
everybody except for the ebony maw who
basically show up here now remember when
it comes to Thanos and the Black Order
for the most part they're given a lot of
leeway
right like Santos is like here's my
instructions complete them I don't care
how you do it as long as you do not come
back here with failure that's basically
the rule and so they're kind of given
free rein and the epidemis no different
when Thanos looked at the ebony mine he
basically says okay look his methods
aren't necessarily normal they're pretty
unorthodox but he gets results and at
the end of the day that's all I care
about because people are asking like
where's the ebony maw we can't
communicate with him telepathically he's
not using his communicator he's
basically gone off the reservation he's
off the radar entirely but Thanos isn't
really worried about that because the
ebony MA always gets results the issue
with this is that the other members are
really the you know Proxima midnight
says look according to name was a
submariner he told me that like the time
stones in Wakanda so we're gonna have to
go to Wakanda now the analyst response
is cool but I'm gonna go down to the to
the inhuman Royal City first I'm gonna
deal with them and we'll find out you
know where that extends to you in the in
the next video but in this one it's kind
of cool because you know like the black
dwarf is like hey man look I'm really
really sorry I failed you know I'm sorry
I screwed up but I'll make up for it man
and that'll just like no no you will not
like you it like what I'm gonna smash
your head into the ground I'm gonna help
you understand your place in a bigger
picture and then you're gonna go sit in
a Cell and you're just gonna wait until
I call for you now this is a pretty
significant thing because for the call
obsidian one of the most important
things that can do is one please Spanos
and two if they please Stannis to hand
their lives over to death that's really
what they shoot for but with Thanos
being displeased it's like the ultimate
failure on their behalf they lose
respect of the other members you know
from the other members of the Cole
obsidian and so the result is that black
dwarf is just kind of in a pretty rough
spot of filling and so what ends up
happening here is like the entire force
of Wakanda Black Panthers shuri all
their soldiers the whole nine yards are
basically forced to look on estado su
invasion fleet moves full-on in to
Wakanda Proxima midnight Corvus glaive
you know super giant the whole
they all basically make their move onto
Wakanda and the question that's left
here is what chance does Wakanda have
what possible hope do they have against
the entire brunt of Thanos's armies
combined with the black order along with
Thanos presumably showing up after he's
done dealing with the Inhumans but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
have this sub button to become part of
the Rob core for you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you